tina miller is here in the studio we're
just mesmerized yeah we're mesmerizing
first bettina take off your top one and
look at those arms
your arms number one when you came out
on the stage but so i was there opening
night and before when you walked down
the stage before you even opened your
mouth the audience went wild what i know
that felt good take us to that moment oh
my god it it it has felt so amazing i
mean every night the witch's entrance
applause is just
i mean we all get applause the
characters i think they're just beloved
characters people love this show they
they love these people and so to be able
to walk out on stage
with that yeah kind of you know what i
mean it just kind of sets you off and
you just get excited to to perform now
you said that the witch is often and
also when you came out in that purple
too the audience that was a big gas
moment too you know that you say the
witch is often misunderstood and now
you're the mother of a four four almost
five-year-old daughter yeah does that
change your perception in how you play
the witch or what you think of the witch
yeah i mean i guess my idea of what the
witch was when an an earlier
interpretations of the show of me doing
the show like early on when i was 21
singing music from the show you know the
witch's scene is the villain she's the
one who's you know the mastermind of
this whole thing she sets everything in
motion and you kind of can play her dark
and
mean and all of these things and
coming back to it now
being the mother of a five-year-old and
really understanding what she's fighting
for like why she is the way she is she's
fighting to keep
her daughter safe you know the world is
twisted and it's messed up and she knows
what the world is and so it's this
mother really just trying to keep her
daughter safe and protected and
connected
in other words there are times now where
you think it would be kind of nice to
put my daughter in a tower
well i mean listen yeah yeah because you
know the world is a scary place right
now and so yeah have raising a daughter
in this in this this climate you know it
yeah i understand her a lot and so i was
able to put myself into it really we
were saying back uh backstage that you
know this performance is so uniquely
your own yeah um there have been other
actresses who've played the witch uh
including famously bernadette peters but
you have such a unique take on it and
what you're telling us now is so
interesting that you see yourself as a
mother and so when i was watching patina
i thought to myself this is how a mother
would
react if she was trying to protect a
child from the dangers of the world you
might not always be funny or cute but
you might be a little angry and you
might be a little aggressive with people
around you meaning the other cast
members yeah and you know you you you
might sometimes act in a way that's not
appropriate right because
it's it's human nature right like no
one's perfect and she's mothering in the
only way that she knows how right you
know and it's not always pretty and so
when she does the thing
with rapunzel she can't undo that right
like so it's the mistakes and all of
these things and you you see her long
for her daughter towards the second act
and wanting to to be there with her but
she's kind of
she messed it up so you've also got the
broadway stage you've also got a very
successful tv show second second season
of raising canaan yes the difference
between tv and broadway for you is what
do you have a preference
i don't have a preference but i will say
i i i love being able to stick with a
character like on the show that i'm
doing now uh raising raising kanan you
know august 14th i love being able to
tell this character's story in more of a
long form and and figuring out how she
ticks and being able to following her
being able to follow her but then for
the stage you know it's the audience you
know there's nothing like telling a
story night after night making it
different trying something new working
on it and getting that audience feedback
right there in the moment talk about
feedback your little girl was there
opening night
i wish i would have known that because i
would have loved to have watched her
does she have a favorite song do you
sing with her yes she loves the witch's
wrap
how does it go greens greens nothing but
greens parsley peppers cabbages and
celery she loves so it's kind of like a
nice cool thing for us does she eat her
greens though at dinner
she doesn't but i'm going to start using
that
i'm going to it might help thank you
thank you for that and shout out to
understudies patina you were an
understudy on sister right and then all
of a sudden you find yourself you're the
lead actress nominated for two call it
wonder studies man because what they do
is it's it's super human man what they
do so
all right bettina miller thank you very
much you can see into the woods at the
st james theater on broadway eight shows
a week she's got those arms for right
it's only eight weeks